how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some pretty big details revealed
about some of marvel's phase four
projects including a huge plot detail
about
thor love and thunder revealed by
natalie portman herself
and we also have some spider-man 3 news
which of course always excites everybody
especially with the news that the
multiverse is going to probably play a
very prominent role in spider-man 3.
and it looks like we're going to be
getting the official title of spider-man
3 in the mcu pretty soon and i'll break
down
everything you need to know in this
video if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a loki funko pop
so so far all the things we know about
thor love and thunder
lead us to believe that this movie is
going to be absolutely
crazy yes even crazier than thor
ragnarok
[Music]
taika waititi has already confirmed that
space sharks are going to be a part of
thor love and thunder he also himself
said that the movie is going to be
insane and more over the top than thor
ragnarok
he said that it's like he asked a bunch
of kids for ideas about the movie and
said yes to all of them
chris hemsworth also had a lot of really
good things to say about the script as
well
in one interview he said after reading
the script i can say that i am very
excited
for sure there will be a lot of love and
a lot of lightning in this production
as he laughs i'm glad that after all
that happened in avengers in-game i'm
still part of the marvel universe and we
can continue the story of thor
of course i can't tell you anything
about the plot but to satisfy your
curiosity
i'll say that i had a lot more fun
reading the script than on thor ragnarok
and that proved something
because this movie was brilliant so
according to chris hemsworth
this movie is already better than thor
ragnarok which is saying something
because that movie was amazing but also
according to taikawatiti
and chris hemsworth this movie is going
to have a lot of romance in it and
that's of course where jane foster
returns now we already know that she's
going to be a female thor
in the movie and that she's going to be
worthy enough to lift the hammer
but natalie portman has recently
revealed a pretty big plot about thor
loving thunder that involves her and
jane foster's story
yesterday natalie portman sat down with
yahoo.com to discuss her new children's
book and
major moments of her career and of
course while she was doing the interview
with yahoo they asked her if she could
reveal
anything about thor love and thunder in
which she actually did give us
a pretty big plot point about the movie
she said
i can't tell you that much i'm really
excited
i'm starting to train to get muscles if
there can be
all these female superheroes the more of
them they are
the better it is i'm trying to think
it's based on the graphic novel
of the mighty thor she's going through
cancer treatment and
is a superhero on the side this is
actually really big
natalie portman tells us in the
interview that the movie is going to be
based off of the novel the mighty thor
and her character is going to have
breast cancer just like in the comics
now cancer is actually a pretty big part
of jane foster becoming worthy to lift
mjolnir in the comics
and in the comics thor actually becomes
unworthy so in the story jane foster
gets breast cancer and thor gets deemed
no longer worthy to wield mjolnir and
the hammer was left abandoned on the
moon
the frost giants then invade earth and a
new
mighty thor arrives to save the day now
for a very long time
for about seven issues her identity was
a mystery
and eventually thor would go and try to
reclaim mjolnir and reclaim the title of
thor but after seeing her in action he
acknowledges that she
is indeed worthy now the actual thor
goes on to try and figure out who this
new thor is for a pretty long time
and he kind of does suspect that it is
jane foster but he ends up ruling her
out considering the fact that she's
going through chemotherapy and he
considers her too weak to beat thor
eventually enough happens and thor begs
the new thor to reveal who she
is and she eventually does tell him that
it is her
jane foster now the only problem here is
that every time jane foster turns into
thor
the transformation process makes her
cancer worse when she turns into thor it
actually gets rid of all of the toxins
in her body and
in doing so gets rid of the chemotherapy
treatment so her being thor
is actually killing her however when
thor finally does find out who she is
she says i am dr jane foster and i will
not stop being the mighty thor
even though it is killing me she
continues to go on as thor and she also
goes on to become an avenger
she ends up working with dr steven
strange to heal some of her patients but
at one point
doctor strange examines her and tells
her that if she becomes thor
one more time it'll kill her however
when mangog
attacks asgar she turns into thor again
anyways
and doctor strange ended up being right
she ends up sacrificing mjolnir
and her life to defeat mangog so
ultimately the cancer that jane foster
has
and the combination of her being thor as
well do end up killing her so there is a
possibility that we could see jane
foster
die in the mcu now often times in the
comics
death isn't really that permanent and
odin's son aka the original thor
and odin himself find a way to resurrect
her thor odin's son ends up becoming
worthy again and goes on to take on the
mantle of thor
meanwhile jane foster decides to go on
and focus on her health and eventually
her cancer does go into remission so
there is a good chance that jane foster
could make it out of thor love and
thunder alive but if she does in fact
die
there's a good chance that she'll stay
dead we've already had plenty of
opportunities for people to be
resurrected in avengers in-game
after the fight with thanos the avengers
had the infinity stones and if they
really wanted to they could have had
somebody extremely powerful
like captain marvel use the stones to
bring back tony to bring back vision
and any others that they may have lost
with the exception of black widow
because she was the sacrifice for the
soul stone
but with one division coming out and
bringing vision back in a really weird
way
anything's possible at this point in
time but let's also consider the fact
that we may be seeing
an unworthy thor in thor love and
thunder now of course the movies don't
always copy the comics 100
or nearly 50 most of the time but
natalie portman did say that the movie
is going to be based off of the mighty
thor
and in the mighty thor thor is unworthy
for a good majority of the time
now we kind of saw thor go through this
already in avengers in game
four was kind of a mess in avengers in
game and he himself didn't think he was
worthy until he went back in time and
was able to lift mjolnir
[Music]
i'm still worthy so it could be that
thor has already gone through the
unworthy phase and we're just going to
pick up from this and thor love and
thunder or he could go
through a phase where he is completely
unworthy to lift up the hammer and that
could be how jane foster
ends up becoming thor and it also could
be possible that jane foster having
cancer is what brings
thor and jane back together it also
could be why they broke up
she could have broke it off with thor
because she was sick but after avengers
in game where thor goes off and tries to
find himself he could discover that what
he truly wants is a relationship
in which he would track down jane and
try to start a relationship again
and who knows perhaps marvel could even
do a reverse where jane becoming thor
actually cures her of her cancer
entirely after all the direction that
marvel's going they'll probably want
natalie portman to stick around in the
mcu
as a jane foster thor for a pretty long
time so lots of romance coming lots of
crazy
insane things coming for thor love and
thunder and to top this video off as i
mentioned in the beginning we have some
really awesome spider-man 3 news
it looks like spider-man 3 is going to
start filming in just a little over a
week from now
there have been notes going up around
parking lots in new york stating that
pretty soon parking is going to be
closed
due to filming now on this sign it says
shoot day
and date friday 10 16 2020
shoot time 6 a.m to 7 p.m and the
project's name is serenity
now which has already been confirmed to
be the working title for
spider-man 3. now this isn't the
official title for spider-man 3 it's
just the working title they do this for
every marvel movie
so this is great news we're going to
find out a lot more about spider-man 3
very very soon when they start shooting
including most likely what is going to
be the official title of the movie
tom holland has actually done an
exceptional job at not giving away any
spoilers for the movie yet
but once filming starts we're definitely
going to be getting some leaks as there
are going to be people who are going to
sneak some photos and of course videos
so a lot more for spider-man 3
coming soon but in the meantime let me
know what you think about this major
plot detail for
thor love and thunder and do you think
that natalie portman's jane foster
is going to die let me know your
thoughts about thor love and thunder and
spider-man 3 in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on
anything relating to the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof
bye